sonríe y cuida de su imagen
el aspecto de Richi sunat transmite
fiabilidad y meticulosidad al mismo
tiempo
nació en Southampton al sur de
Inglaterra sunat de 43 años es el mayor
de tres hijos de una familia de origen
indio estudio política filosofía y
economía en prestigiosas universidades
como Oxford y Stanford y se abrió paso
en el partido conservador en 2015 allí
juramento sobre el bagabat guita el
libro sagrado del hinduismo
cinco años después fue nombrado ministro
de finanzas durante el mandato de Boris
Johnson y su paquete ayudas lo convirtió
en uno de los miembros más populares del
gobierno
hoy estoy anunciando una expansión de
nuestro esquema de apoyo laboral
específicamente para proteger los
puestos de las personas que trabajan en
empresas que podrían cerrar
su aprobación se puso en la cuerda floja
Cuando acabó con gran parte de las
ayudas Y subió los impuestos al
levantarse la restricciones y se vio en
el ojo del huracán cuando fue multado
por asistir a las fiestas del conocido
escándalo party
cuando dimitió del gobierno de Johnson y
luego lanzó su candidatura para Primer
Ministro muchos vieron un acto de
traición el exministro de finanzas
prometió que puede darle un nuevo rumbo
a la debilitada economía británica y
atacó las políticas económicas de
listros
mi mensaje para el partido y el país es
simple tengo un plan para dirigir
nuestra economía a través de estos
vientos en contra necesitamos volver a
los valores económicos conservadores
tradicionales Y eso significa honestidad
y responsabilidad no cuentos de hadas
y sus predicciones se cumplieron cuando
fracasaron las medidas de Trust un
acierto que le dio un último empujón
para llegar al 10 de Downey